let's start by reviewing aldehyde and
ketone reactivity because this will tell
us a lot about how and why enol and enol
aids form
here's acetone a simple ketone oxygen is
more electronegative than carbon and so
the electrons that are shared in this
bond are pulled toward the oxygen
they're whizzing around in this bond but
because oxygen attracts the electrons
more they spend more time near it and we
get a dipole in this molecule we can
also show a resonance form for acetone
that puts a formal negative charge on
oxygen and a positive charge on carbon
this contributes significantly to the
carbonyl groups reactivity so when an
electron rich atom bonds to a carbonyl
it's going to do so at the Delta
positive carbon atom in a grignard
reaction the grignard carbon has lots of
negative charge concentrated on it so
the nucleophilic carbon of the grignard
reagent is going to attack at the
electro positive carbon atom pushing the
electrons up onto oxygen
then a second stage of the reaction is
carried out where dilute acid is added
to give the oxygen a proton and form an
alcohol
acid-catalyzed additions of nucleophiles
are also possible with aldehydes and
ketones
since the oxygen atom of the carbonyl is
electron rich it can attack a proton
once it's protonated the positive charge
on oxygen makes the adjacent carbon atom
even more electropositive in the
reaction I've shown here the nucleophile
is one of the oxygen atoms of the
molecule below the arrow ethylene glycol
in several steps we eventually get
bonding of both oxygen atoms of ethylene
glycol to the carbonyl carbon forming
this functional group called a keto the
dipole in acetone also affects the
hydrogen atoms that are adjacent to the
carbonyl they feel the pull of the
dipole in the molecule and consequently
become more acidic with a pKa of 27 now
this might not seem too acidic but
compared to a regular unsubstituted
hydrocarbon which has a pKa of around 50
this is a substantial decrease
the acidity of the alpha protons allows
them to be deprotonated sodium hydroxide
can attack the acidic proton and we push
electrons all the way through the
carbonyl to show how formation of the
anion is stabilized by conjugation
there is another resonance form that
puts a negative charge on carbon so an
enol a is a carbon nucleophile
we went from a compound that undergoes
nucleophilic attack to something that
can do the attacking a compound with
analogous reactivity called an enol can
be formed under acid catalyzed
conditions the mechanism begins the same
as the acid catalyzed addition we showed
above where the electrons on the Delta
negative oxygen can attack a proton on
sulfuric acid in this case protonation
of the carbonyl oxygen makes the alpha
hydrogen's even more acidic and they can
be deprotonated this is reasonable
because the conjugate base of sulfuric
acid is highly resonance stabilized and
not very nucleophilic typically there is
a bit of water in even the most
concentrated solutions of acid so under
acidic conditions we formed an enol
which is also a nucleophile now that
we've looked at how emails and enol
Eights are formed let's look briefly at
their reactivity the first reaction will
look at is alpha halogenation this is
going to introduce a halogen atom at the
carbon adjacent to the carbonyl we'll
carry out this reaction under acidic
conditions using acetic acid and bromine
in the first step our enol is generated
then a lone pair on oxygen can push back
down allowing the double bond of the
enol to attack bromine displacing BR
minus now we get a positive charge on
oxygen which can be deprotonated with
acetate which we formed when we
protonated our carbonyl compound to form
our enol in the first place
so why are these alpha halogenated
carbonyl compounds useful well they're
great substrates for sn2 reactions and
we can displace the bromine with a
variety of nucleophiles here I'm showing
a reaction with dimethyl amine to make
an alpha amino compound we can also form
carbon-carbon bonds using enols and
enolates which is very important in
synthetic organic chemistry where the
goal is to build up more complex carbon
skeletons from simpler molecules to show
this alkylation reaction I'm going to
first deep protonate acetone to form an
enolate now we need a little bit of
fancier chemistry here the enol a and
enol forming reactions that i've shown
above are actually in equilibrium when
made with NaOH or sulfuric acid but to
make this alkylation reaction proceed
with any sort of control we're going to
need some fancier chemistry here we're
going to use lithium diisopropyl amador
Lda to generate this enolate completely
Lda has two isopropyl groups and a
negative charge on nitrogen this makes
it a very hindered base so it can't
attack at our carbonyl as a means are
known to do instead it's big and bulky
and it can only get at this alpha
hydrogen it's also much more basic than
sodium hydroxide so we can treat our
compound with one equivalent of Lda and
generate our enolate completely now in a
second step we can add in the alkyl
halide since we used up all of our Lda
we don't have to worry about our base
reacting with the bromide the enolate
attacks at the electro positive carbon
next to the bromide leaving group and
our final molecule extends our carbon
chain by three carbon atoms this
reaction works best with alkyl halides
that are not hindered so primary alkyl
halides are a good choice for this
reaction before we wrap up I do need to
mention that enol a alkylation has lots
of limitations and in another lesson we
will go over these limitations and how
to work around them